what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really exciting
news about Deadpool 3 and it looks like
we might have discovered what exactly
Magneto's role is going to be in this
film now everybody was already super
excited for Deadpool 3 on its own just
to be in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but then they went and announced that
Hugh Jackman is returning to play his
iconic Wolverine getting fans even more
excited now if the film just stopped
simply at this it would still be an
incredible film simply Wolverine coming
back and interacting with Deadpool and
really just Hugh Jackman interacting
with Ryan Reynolds on screen is just a
win for everybody but then they tell us
that this is going to be a multiversal
movie that Deadpool and Wolverine are
going on a sort of Multiverse road trip
together then we start getting reports
that the old original X-Men from the fox
Universe are going to appear in Deadpool
3 in different universes Deadpool and
Wolverine travel throughout the
Multiverse which is just super super
exciting but today we find out a little
bit more as we find out the working
title for Deadpool 3. now for those of
you who may not be aware working titles
are simply what they use for production
they don't end up being the official
title of the movie and in Deadpool's
case Deadpool 2 is simply titled
Deadpool 2. so Deadpool 3 might just
simply be titled Deadpool 3. however
more often than not the working titles
do give us a little bit of insight as to
what the plot of the movie could
actually be and in our case the working
title for Deadpool 3 seemingly gives us
some insight as to what Magneto's role
in this movie is going to be and it
actually lines up with some reports from
insiders about his role as well now this
report is coming from the
cosmiccircus.com they have reported on
this and they have stated that the
working title for Deadpool 3 is tidal
wave and we believe that this could be
referring to the comic run ultimatum and
the story run for ultimatum does fit in
in with the reports that we have heard
from some insiders recently in the
ultimatum run New York City is hit by a
massive tidal wave this is caused by
Magneto seeking Revenge after the deaths
of his kids and the cover actually
quotes him when he says when God didn't
like what he created he washed it all
away in 40 days and 40 nights I will do
it in three now it's a pretty cool story
and it definitely demonstrates how
powerful Magneto is and according to
some previous reports we're going to see
how powerful Magneto is in Deadpool 3.
in fact one of the main reasons that
Deadpool could be Multiverse traveling
is because of the TVA and Owen Wilson's
character now we did a video about this
not too long ago but in case you missed
it we found out that the TVA might
actually be seeking the help of Deadpool
after they arrest him of course at the
end of Deadpool 2 we saw Deadpool take
Cable's time travel device and go to
different timelines and kind of make
them exactly what he wanted them to be
he brought his girlfriend back he he
technically killed himself in a
different Universe more than once
actually he killed his old Deadpool self
and his old Green Lantern self and he
has already interacted with Wolverine in
that post-credit scene from Deadpool 2.
So based off of everything that we've
learned from the Loki series obviously
the TVA is going to be after Deadpool
and based off of what we've heard he's
kind of going to have a pretty similar
story to Loki he'll get captured by the
TVA but instead of being pruned Owen
Wilson's Mobius will want to actually
use him for a different job according to
Insider reports there is going to be a
universe that is ruled by the X-Men that
the TVA simply cannot overtake or prune
and this is where the working title
comes in tidal wave perhaps this
universe is the movie comic book
adaptation of the ultimatum run perhaps
in this universe Magneto and the rest of
the X-Men and the Brotherhood of mutants
have done many different things
including a massive Title Wave to Rule
New York City but also the world and
also if you want to check out the
ultimatum run and other awesome Comics
as well be sure to check out my friends
over at comicbookdirect.com they have
created a website and company that makes
comic book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now there is going to be a
little bit of a difference in this
supposed Universe where Magneto is going
to be ruling apparently in this universe
everybody all of the mutants at least
are going to be on Magneto's side even
Professor Xavier and the rest of the
X-Men they're all going to be with
Magneto so basically it's going to be a
world that is simply ruled by mutants
now as far as if this is going to be
caused by the actual death of his
children in this universe and if an
actual tidal wave is going to take place
that we're unsure of right now although
if they were going to take over the
world I'm sure causing a massive tidal
wave would be a great attack and if all
of the mutants are in charge of this
world of course that would make it
pretty hard for the TVA to prune it
especially if they are using things like
Sentinels they could be using Sentinels
and some type of technology to Monitor
and observe and be alerted when the TVA
shows up it could have them everywhere
scouting one way or another we know that
the TVA is going to be unable to prune
this world which is why they need the
help of Deadpool he's not your ordinary
mutant and he does have his own special
way of doing things and the TVA is going
to know that much like Loki Mobius is
going to have studied Deadpool in
different universes a lot and basically
know everything about him however much
like our Loki and the Loki series I'm
sure are Deadpool in the Deadpool movie
is going to be different from the other
variants now one thing we're not 100
sure about is if Wolverine is in this
universe that he's going to have to go
to that is ruled by mutants or if he
meets him somewhere else along the way
because if we know Deadpool we know that
Deadpool is probably going to be just
like Loki but even worse Loki manages to
escape the TVA and get his hands on a
teleporter eventually but both Loki and
Sylvie wanted to make their way back to
the TVA Deadpool is probably not going
to want to make his way back to the TBA
he's probably Gonna Wanna Go Multiverse
hopping and based off of what we've
heard that's exactly what's gonna happen
now there is always a chance that he
meets Wolverine in this universe where
the X-Men Rule and Wolverine perhaps
isn't a part of the X-Men team or the
Brotherhood of mutants team perhaps he's
just a character on the sidelines that
Deadpool runs into in that universe and
ultimately ends up helping him and then
maybe goes along with Deadpool or maybe
Deadpool kidnaps him and that's where
their Bromance could begin and
ultimately this would make sense because
we have been told by Ryan Reynolds and
Hugh Jackman that Deadpool and Wolverine
are going to fight each other so
Deadpool showing up to a universe where
he essentially has to kill the entire
X-Men definitely sets up a fight between
him and Wolverine but Wolverine not
being a really go with the flow type of
guy also sets it up to where he could be
different and apart from the X-Men
ultimately end up working with Deadpool
also not to mention this does sort of
set us up for a great storyline in the
comics which is Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe and this could be
Deadpool kills the fox universe or
whatever Universe they want to deem this
to be if they truly are taking
inspiration from that story which it
does seem like they are then this is
perfect Deadpool has to go and kill all
of the Marvel characters in this
universe and it's a universe that is
going to be ruled by Marvel characters
it's perfect but what we have to keep in
mind is that eventually he is going to
have to make his way to the MCU now like
I mentioned Deadpool is probably going
to steal a device and is going to be
able to travel throughout the Multiverse
and that's definitely what he's going to
do in fact he's kind of already done it
with Cable's time traveler device so
more than likely Deadpool is going to
cause some serious repercussions for the
Multiverse and I'm pretty sure some of
those repercussions are going to be
incursions which is going to be one of
the huge threats of Secret Wars universe
is colliding into each other threatening
the destruction of the entire Multiverse
so that is definitely how Deadpool is
going to kind of get into the fight when
it comes to Secret Wars in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which is really
exciting to finally have Deadpool in the
universe that we have with Thor the Hulk
Falcon the Scarlet Witch Doctor Strange
Spider-Man you name it it's super
exciting and based off of what we've
heard so far and what could happen this
movie is gonna be fantastic but hey let
me know all of your thoughts about this
in the comments down below we also have
a patreon a website and a Discord now so
I'll link those down below be sure to
check them out also don't forget to like
the video subscribe and leave a comment
so you can enter our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5 to
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
the winner get to pick and we pick a
winner at the end of each month don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf
foreign